Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, du bist doch eigentlich auch schon länger in dieser Sendung. Wer bist du denn eigentlich? Erzähl doch mal ein bisschen was von dir.
Logbuchen Netzpolitik äh der Counter geht auf eins fünf drei die einhundertdreiundfünfzigste Sendung. Ninus.
In der Metaebene.
Mir willst du nix erzählen von dir? Allen anderen erzählst du was.
Nein, ich habe doch gar nichts von mir erzählt. Wie? Nee.
Nee? Nee. Achso.
Nee, ich habe da, ich halte da nichts von.
Was hast du denn erzählt? Ich habe über Lokbuch erzählt. Ich hoffe nur Gutes.
Logbuch Netzpolitik erzählt. Ja, ich habe die Sendung in höchsten Tönen gelobt.
Anständig.
Äh nee, der ich war bei äh das ist aber schon etwas länger her, äh dass wir das aufgenommen haben und das ist auch schon etwas länger her, dass das veröffentlicht wurde, ist dann aber irgendwie so in dem äh Camp waren irgendwie bei mir untergegangen und zwar gibt es eine,
Podcast, Episode des Podcast Sendungsbewusstsein.
Von Mirko Blitz.
Von Mirko Blitzer ist ein eigentlich ein ganz interessantes Konzept, eigentlich uneigentlich auch.
Genau, ja äh interviewt und Podcasterin.
Podcast da. Und genau, äh Podcaster und Podcasterin über ihre Podcasts. Und ähm.
Das warum, wieso, weshalb und überhaupt.
Genau und eigentlich hat er also eigentlich mag er dann wohl auch gerne über die Personen reden, aber das war ja nicht so gerne.
Nee, ich finde das, also keine Ahnung. Ist halte ich nicht für weiß nicht. Wer nicht einen Podcast über mich selber machen wollen würde, dann würde ich einen Podcast über mich selber machen, aber ich finde irgendwie Themen interessanter als Personen.
Deswegen möchte ich lieber über Themen reden. Aber wir haben ein bisschen über so Hintergrund und so, man erfährt glaube ich auch das ein oder andere.
Die ein oder andere Petite hast du heraus äh.
Ja
Rausgelassen.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, weiß nicht so, wie ähm wie das auch so mit diesen Bundestagssachen ist und ähm.
Ich fand das ganz interessant. Also oder ich fand das ganz interessant, mal darüber zu reden. Das merkt man auch in dem Podcast, weil ich äh ich glaube dem Mirko, der beendet irgendwann die Sendung, weil er nicht mehr kann. Weil ich ihm irgendwie.
Zugetextet haben.
Ohr blutig gekaut habe und äh
Ja, ich fand, also ich fand das in insofern interessant, weil man ja auch selten sich mal so zurücklehnt und darüber reflektiert. Und das war
kurz vor der hundertfünfzigsten Sendung bei ihm aufm Balkon und dann habe ich halt einfach auch mal so,
ein bisschen darüber nachgedacht, weil er dann so fragt, was was gibt dir Podcast und so, was hörst du für Podcasts oder so, ne? Und dann haben wir da
Das fand ich mal ganz interessant, weil die Frage stellt man sich ja jetzt nicht unbedingt, dass man sie irgendwie so zu Hause sitzt und sagt, ich Podcast, weil und ähm,
Das war eigentlich ganz, ganz interessant, da mal drüber zu quatschen.
Und jetzt müssen wir hier übrigens alles umkrempeln. Ich habe einen neuen Fünf-Jahres-Plan.
Na endlich.
Ja. Auf YouTube wollen wir ja nicht. Willst du ja nicht, ich ja schon. Ja.
Hauptstrom? Nein, danke.
Nee, fand ich ganz interessant. Dann nachher dann äh habe ich ihm aber erst war ich habe ihm dann so Druck gemacht, habe gesagt, jetzt haben wir, jetzt haben wir ja ein Jahr gebraucht, bis wir endlich mal die Folge aufgenommen haben und jetzt brauchst du hier nur einen Tag zum Schneiden oder was?
Oder zum zum Aufbereiten schneiden macht er nicht, aber,
Verschonoted hatte die Episode sehr äh liebevoll. Ja und da waren auch schon andere Leute zu Gast. Hier wie heißt der? Tim Prito. Ähm.
Mhm. Ähm genau.
Martin Fischer von hier ähm,
dem äh Staatsbürger Brunde Podcast. Ja, so jetzt gerade irgendwie so, du hast halt, ich gucke grade auf dieses Logo, äh auf dieses Episoden, Episoden Cover und da steht halt Sendungsbewusstsein, Sendungswunsch. Martin Fischer vom,
Sendungsbewusstsein.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ralf Stockmann. Äh Sven Mencke von Kulinarikers ähm Stefanie Dahn,
Podcast vorgedacht. Nico Herzog, Kathrin Röneke, die äh die hatte, genau, man kann sich nämlich dann, wenn man da war, dann darf man sich die dann darf man sich zwei weitere Gäste wünschen,
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, ob der Mirko sich darüber im Klaren ist, was.
Hast du das gesagt oder hast du das danach gesagt? Also.
Das habe ich in der Sendung gesagt.
Ah, weißt du's noch? Ich weiß es gerade nicht mehr. Ja, sag mal.
Nee, ist ja ganz am Ende der Sendung. Da würde ich ja jetzt spoilern.
Der aber die Kathrin hatte, glaube ich, mich äh äh sich nicht gewünscht. Als Gast.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wen ich mir, wenn ich denn da ach so, doch, ich weiß wieder.
Ja, mich, mich nicht. Und die Claudia Krell war da, von den WikiGeks. Dann haben wir jetzt, glaube ich, auch alle genannt.
Habe ich jetzt irgendjemanden übergangen? Nee. Doch, Nico Herzog vom Bildsprache Podcast bin ich übergangen. Der war auch da. Ja, ist auf jeden Fall ganz, war, keine Ahnung, ganz lustig. Ich glaube, da das ist eigentlich ein ganz,
Wenn man sich jetzt für die Person im Podcast interessiert, ich habe das auch in der Sendung gesagt, ich interessiere mich weniger für Personen oder für Personen, die keine Themen behandeln,
Also ich find's zum Beispiel auch bei der Freakshow könntet ihr echt mal wieder mehr über Max reden.
Äh nee, weiß ich nicht.
Hörer interessieren sich für Personen, weil das ist halt das, was dieses Medium einfach auch ausmacht, so. Und äh sicherlich auch dieses Medium.
Das ist ja gut, aber ich will ja ich möchte ja also es geht mir einfach nur darum, ich bin jetzt weniger an Podcasts interessiert von,
Person, die wenig mitzuteilen haben, was über ihre eigene Person hinausgeht.
Na klar, nee, das ist äh.
Da gab's wohl, habe ich jetzt auch in der Folge mit Ralf gehört, da muss es wohl hier in deiner äh in eurer Podcastgate Sendung Sendung skate, das ist ja ein Forum für,
Sendegeld. Das ist ja ein Forum für Podcaster. Da gibt's ja, glaube ich, eine einen Flame War zwischen,
den Lava-Podcastern und den Nicht-Lava-Podcastern oder sowas. Da kam auf jeden Fall dieses Team Lava-Podcast hat er erwähnt. Da habe ich nämlich auch Aufkleber vom Camp,
Podcast.
Die sind vom letzten Podcast Workshop. Das war eher eine ironische Aufgriff dieses etwas gestrandeten Artikels, der.
Dieser Nikolas Seemarkt, der mit dem der Leuchten vorher.
Der sich äh ja nee, der sich auch vollkommen falsch verstanden äh fühlt, was die Auswirkungen betrifft. Das das ist auch alles,
Das ist, glaube ich, auch alles total äh.
Das soll, soll jeder da machen, äh was äh er oder sie will, Formate finden sich äh von alleine und.
Ist auch eine Kunst und ähm ich würde ohnehin zu labern eher
sagen, ja, also es ist ja so ein so ein Dehokativ. Nee, aber ja, also erstens ja und zweitens, da hast du's aufgegriffen, drittens ist es halt einfach äh eine Frage, wie man das halt findet.
Gesinnt Gespräche. So, wenn man das halt,
nicht gut findet oder abtun will, dann kann man's halt labern nennen und daraus entsteht ja dann gleich wieder so Laber Pride, ja, wo dann eben dann diese Team Lava,
Podcast Aufkleber statt. Ja also ist doch alles vollkommen in Ordnung. Ich denke äh das Medium hat da einfach genug Raum und eigentlich auch auf jeder,
Schiene da schon bemerkenswertes hervorgebracht. Also genauso wenig, also nicht nicht, dass ich der Meinung bin, es muss einfach nur locker dahergeredet werden und das, dann passt das schon
genauso wenig bin ich aber auch der Auffassung, dass so dieses was in dieser Debatte mein Geschmack
vollkommen sinnloser Weise immer so daneben gehalten wird so
hier der arrangierte wohlgeschnittene Feature Style äh hochqualitative äh äh Podcast
der vielleicht shiny shiny anzusehen ist und auch toll anzuhören ist und alles super und am Ende hat er vielleicht auch noch,
gute Inhalte. Das kann man halt alles machen, aber jeder muss halt das Medium wählen, wo die.
Eigene Botschaft letztlich am besten rüberkommt und wo wo das, was ich äh so ein Medium als Ziel gesetzt hat, einfach am effizientesten umgesetzt wird. Und das kann halt bei dem einen so
bei der anderen so sein und das äh ist letzten Endes entscheidend. Deswegen bin ich da unbeteiligt in dieser Debatte.
Ich möchte da auch jetzt gar nicht äh.
Es gab auch kein also mir wäre das neu, dass es da jetzt,
sende geht ein. Da gab's noch gar keine es gibt überhaupt gar keine Podcaster-Flamos. Die sind alle total süß und piesig und nett und herzig und so. Das hast du ja auch sicherlich gemerkt beim.
Ich will auch, also ich höre sehr viele Podcasts aus der Kategorie Podcast, weil man muss ja auch irgendwie, wenn man einschlafen will, was hören. Ja und das äh da ja natürlich.
Ja, ich höre dir auch mehr zum Aufwachen.
Aber ich möchte, ich ich will ich möchte ungern selber einen machen. Ich versuche selber keinen zu machen. Wahrscheinlich gelingt mir das auch nicht.
Streng dich mal an heute.
Wer diese Sendung hört die Sendungsbewusstsein null null neun der wird merken dass sich wahrscheinlich durchaus auch Lava Podcast.
Ich kann auch labern, Podcast.
Sitzt halt jemand und kaut dem anderen ein Ohr ab, bis er bis er nicht mehr kann, über zwei Stunden und zweiundzwanzig Minuten.
Ja, irgendwann. Zwei Stunden. Du bist dann irgendwann thematisch, du bist dann thematisch irgendwann auch wirklich abgeritten.
Thema ist, ich finde klar, ich möchte kein Laber-Podcast machen. Also der, das hat durchaus,
durchaus eine ironische Komponente, ähm die auch mir nicht entgangen ist,
Da wünsche ich äh ja. Also Mirko kommt da wenig zu Wort. Vielleicht die eigentlich auch alleine machen können. Aber das ist ja auch gut. Ich meine, das soll ja, das ist ja sein Konzept, das da,
die Leute sich einen von 'ner von der Leber labern,
Habe ich auch irgendwann schon mal bei äh wir müssen Reden gemacht. Das ist aber Jahre her. Ja äh kann man ja auch noch kurz hier raussuchen.
Podcast. Gut, wollen wir uns an unserem äh Kernformat äh widmen und mal wieder das Geschehen im Netz politischen äh Bereich schildern.
Ich wollte eigentlich jetzt, ich bin jetzt mich so grade warm gelabert.
Grade warme. Ich kann auch noch ein bisschen von meinen äh meinen Erlebnissen diese Woche äh berichten. Ich.
Will ja labern.
Ich war gerade bei einer schönen Veranstaltung, ja. Bei Jugend hackt.
Jugend hackt, das ist sehr gut. Wer bin ich auch äh im Oktober.
Ich auch, aber ich wollte, weil ich bisher immer alle Termine verpeilt habe,
wollte ich da mal sein und war zufällig in Hamburg und hab mir da mal den Auftakt am Freitagabend angeschaut und das sollten wir alles ganz gut gefallen. Also das.
Was war denn da?
Da findet sich ja dann sozusagen die Teilnehmer schon, also wer jetzt von Jugendtag noch nichts mitbekommen hat, kurze Erläuterung, das ist halt ein der begrüßenswerte Initiative von der Open Knowledge, äh Foundation und glaube ich noch ein paar anderen Partnern, wo halt Jugendliche,
die Bock auf Hacken haben, eingeladen werden ja ein Wochenende mal so richtig in Diskurs zu gehen um nur zusammen und werden dann,
motiviert äh sich doch mal was einfallen zu lassen, was sie so gemeinsam dann über ein äh über das Wochenende hinweg bauen,
Da geht's primär um Software, wenn, glaube ich, auch nicht nur und wenn verschiedene thematische Angebote äh gemacht, also,
stellt quasi so vor, so hier, äh was wäre, wenn ihr was zur Umwelt oder wenn ihr was zur Gesellschaft äh äh macht oder zum Thema Spiele, nicht selten dann auch in Kombination mit so einem Angebot an offenen Daten
ihm gleich die passenden Portale aufgezählt werden, wo man dann gleich sehen kann, so hier, das wäre ein gutes Datenmaterial. Damit könnt ihr äh was schaffen und dann,
finden sich dann halt Teams und denken sich was aus und setzen das dann um. Das ist eine schöne Sache.
Mhm. Da gibt's äh ja genau, Hamburg warst du jetzt, das ist Jugend gewesen, ne, dann gibt.
Genau, gibt's das noch im Westen und im Osten und im Süden, weiß ich nicht. Gibt's auch so Jugend.
Zu dem natürlich.
Ne? Gut. Also im Norden, Süden, Osten und Westen vertreten.
Ich habe jetzt mal einfach, die haben so viele Events auch in noch in den nächsten ja. Ja, das ist ein sehr schönes Projekt, was sehr cool ist. Ähm,
Obwohl ich auch schon ähm einige Teilnehmer,
Kennen und schätzen gelernt habe aus den vergangenen Jahren, die wir dann auch direkt schön brav äh ne,
den Finger drauf haben vom CCC, um da, ne, auch die nächsten.
Talentscouting.
Die haben wir schon gescoutet, genau,
Die haben wir gescoutet. Aber und dann natürlich direkt indoktriniert und so, das äh läuft.
Läuft. Gut. Jetzt aber.
Eure Kinder zu eure Jugendlichen zur Jugend hackt.
Genau oder vergleichbaren Veranstaltungen.
Kommen wir zum Feedback, oh, zur letzten Sendung, da gab's wieder einige äh Anmerkungen und Korrekturen.
Nähergänzungen äh Verbesserungen.
Ergänzung. Verbesserung.
Und zwar hatten wir in der letzten Folge darüber gesprochen, dass das Rechtsgutachten, welches ähm das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz angefertigt hatte und dem,
Generalbundesanwalt eingereicht hatte, um ihn zu motivieren, doch in Sachen Landesfahrrad zu ermitteln.
Nicht davon handelte, dass äh dass der Vorwurf des Landesverrates substantiiert wurde, sondern ähm,
sich mit der Frage beschäftigte, ob die Dokumente, Staatsgeheimnisse sind oder nicht.
Also ob es sozusagen überhaupt ein Anlass gibt, um Landesverrat daraus Schluss fördern zu können, aber nicht die Entscheidung selbst darüber.
Genau und das hatte dich ja äh oder es hatte uns beim äh beim letzten Mal so ein bisschen gewundert, weil wir davon ausgegangen sind, dass doch bitteschön das Gutachten den Landesfahrer zum Inhalt haben wollte und da kommentiert
ein gewisser Andrester äh
das Gutachten vom Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz in Klammern Herrn Müller hatte auch nur die Frage zu beantworten, ob die Dokumente Staatsgeheimnisse sind oder nicht. Welche Straftat uns dann auf dieser Basis vorgeworfen wird, ist nicht Aufgabe des Verfassungsschutzes
in Klammern bitte Sachverhalt prüfen unter allen rechtlichen Gesichtspunkten, sondern des Generalbundesanwalts,
nur halt, dass das Vorhandensein eines Staatsgeheimnisses zwingende Voraussetzung für einen, für die Straftat Landesverrat ist, die Ermittlungen damit also in eine Richtung gelenkt wurden.
Das nochmals äh erklärend hinzugefügt,
Und dann haben wir uns in der letzten Woche über den Zwang bei äh funkenden Geräten unterhalten ausführlich. Und da hat äh,
Cave oder? Ähm.
Gut ergänzt, dass wir nämlich auf diese FCC äh Geschichte relativ wenig eingegangen sind, wo er sagt,
Es gibt auf der FC-Seite noch eine verlängerte Deadline, um die FCC mit Commons zu bewerfen. Ja? Auch für Nicht-Amerikaner,
und dann hat er uns auf eine Seite namens dot org ähm.
Hingewiesen, wo dieser gesamte FC-Vorgang nochmal genauestens auseinandergenommen wird,
inklusive äh Talking Points
wo man, wenn man also mit seinen Abgeordneten irgendwie oder mit Freunden oder mit wem auch immer darüber sprechen will oder zum Beispiel sich an die FCC wenden möchte, ähm,
Dass man da eben äh die entsprechenden äh Argumente ähm nochmal stichpunktartig hat. Und das ist ähm
da sehr inhaltsreich, jetzt haben wir aber das Thema ja auch schon relativ ausführlich besprochen. Für die FCC-Kommentarmöglichkeit gibt's also eine Deadline bis zum neunten Oktober,
zweitausendfünfzehn.
Ausführlich besprochen ist natürlich etwas überzogen. Äh ich hätte das auch gerne noch etwas ausführlicher besprochen in den letzten Sendungen, aber leider und das werdet ihr bemerkt haben, äh war das dann auch genau der Teil in der Sendung, der von unseren
miserabel im Internet äh Verbindung ähm torpediert wurde und deswegen gab's dann nicht so viel interaktive Diskussionen, wie uns das hier manchmal genehm wäre.
Was ist eigentlich dieses orangene Kabel, was da durchs Fenster hängt?
War meine Notlösung danach bis vor Kurzem und jetzt ist wieder alles supi. Jetzt habe ich hier wieder Stellen des Netz, leider nicht gläsern, aber immerhin kommt was an.
Jetzt wo du hier mal wieder in der Metaebene sitzt. Jetzt brauchen wir das gar nicht.
Ja, brauchen eigentlich.
Wieder abschalten.
Kannst du wieder, kündige das mal, das ist ist doch äh,
worum's natürlich eigentlich hier auch geht. Ähm es sollen die Konsumenten wieder unterschiedliche Modelle kaufen,
damit es dann eben Modelle für,
Prosum, Premium, Ultra Power, mega super, kippt, ja, dass du halt dir nicht einfach äh einen zwanzig Euro Tee-Link-Router,
holst und da irgendwie genau deine fette, genaue Konfiguration drauf machst mit VPN und Tor und haste nicht gesehen, sondern dass du dann eben halt den gleichen Router in teurer kaufst mit ähm.
Mit der mit der äh VPN-Funktion noch dabei, ne. Also das das äh,
vermutet er hier also nochmal, dass du eben teurere oder neuere Router kaufst und nicht einfach alte Geräte ähm,
für ein paar Euro ähm kaufst und mit mit geiler äh individueller ausstattet. Statist.
Ja. Kann man vermuten.
WLAN, WLAN haben wir jetzt auch bald wieder. Wir haben wir haben bald mehr WLAN. Tim.
Das gut, weil die Bundesregierung äh.
Das jetzt abschaltet.
Erinnere mich so ein bisschen an diese alte Titanic-Poster noch. Äh endlich Doppelpunkt. Bonn rettet den Wald,
Und da gibt's da so ein Foto von so einem Wald und an dem Baum hängt so ein gelbes Schild. Waldsterben verboten, die Bundesregierung.
Ja, doch, ich erinnere mich.
Ja, so ähnlich ist das jetzt auch beim WLAN-Gesetz.
Ich glaube, das ist noch viel schlimmer.
Hm. Also das ist jetzt ich habe das gar nicht mitbekommen. Beschlossen worden. Also.
Nee, das es gibt jetzt einen Kabinettsbeschluss. Das Gesetz selber haben wir ja schon, also diese Gesetzesplanpläne haben wir ja schon mal behandelt,
Es gibt jetzt ein Kabinettsbeschluss, das heißt, wir sind jetzt in der Phase, wo die Regierung entschieden hat, äh was nun äh heruntergereicht wird ins Parlament, äh.
Was sie gerne hätte.
Ja, was ja in der Regel dann auch mit minimalen Anpassungen, wenn überhaupt ähm beschlossen wird.
Ich denke, dass deutsche Parlament ist unabhängig in seiner Entscheidung und diskutiert das dann lebhaft im Parlament, um dann irgendwie für alle zu den besten Lösungen zu kommen.
Ja, da haben wir im im Sendungsbewusstsein auch nochmal drüber gesprochen,
Ähm das ist wirklich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob's absurd, ob man das jetzt absurd nennen kann oder ob das einfach so eine Neusprechbeispiel ist. Das Ziel dieses Gesetzes soll ja sein,
die Verbreitung von Wählern im öffentlichen Raum.
Und wenn wir uns Deutschland im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern anschauen, dann stellen wir fest, dass.
Wähler nicht besonders verbreitet ist im öffentlichen Raum.
Es ist schon verbreitet, aber eben verschlüsselt. Und wir kommen nicht rein. Ne.
Welches Peter meinst du jetzt, was welches ist.
Irgendeins. Also du kommst ja, wenn ich jetzt in Berlin rumgehe, gibt's sehr viele WLANs, aber die da komme ich nicht rein. Es gibt dann äh das das die Möglichkeiten, einfach mal spontan an einem öffentlichen Ort,
einen Internetzugang zu erlangen sind rar,
und insbesondere an den Stellen, wo sie zur Verfügung stehen, ähm mit ähm mit mit.
Mit Bezahlen verbunden, ne? Also es gibt jetzt irgendwie gut in den, wenn du irgendwie erste Klasse Zug fährst, dann gibt's ein WLAN, da ist aber kein Internet mit dabei. Ähm wenn du,
wenn du.
Das ist so dramatisch. Oh Gott, ich hoffe nicht. Ich hoffe, das ist bald vorbei, damit der Telekom. Oh Gott.
Dann äh was äh ähm,
Wenn du Kabel Deutschland hat er jetzt irgendwie auf irgendwelche Kästen auf WLAN drauf geschnallt, da gibt's dann irgendwie dreißig Minuten umsonst oder sowas, ne?
Aber so wirklich jetzt irgendwie, dass das jetzt hier WLAN irgendwie geil wäre oder so, davon sind wir weit entfernt. Äh im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen Ländern, wo du ähm,
oder coole und einfache Lösungen hast, ne? Und ähm wie Ulf Buhrmeier vom Verein digitale Gesellschaft ja auch, der ja bei uns auch schon zu Gast war, auch seit Jahren sehr geduldig, immer wieder erklärt, ist einer der Hauptgründe dafür.
Die Störerhaftung in Deutschland. Die nämlich besagt, wenn du zu Hause dein äh WLAN mit Leuten teilst und die irgendwie ähm,
Mist machen damit und ähm du dann nicht in der Lage bist die äh die Leute zu benennen und und ans,
ans Messer zu liefern, dann äh haftest du als Störer einfach selber
weil du hast das ermöglicht, was da geschehen ist. Und das führt ja dann auch immer wieder zu so
absurden Situationen wie das man was weiß ich irgendwie mal zwei Wochen in Urlaub fährt und seine Wohnung ähm anderen überlässt und die die machen dann irgendwie den Torent an und dann kommt irgendwie ein paar Wochen später Post und man weiß aber gar nicht mehr äh wo denn jetzt diese Airbnb hin sind und kennt auch nur irgendwie den
Nachnamen und nicht irgendwie eine ladungsfähige Anschrift von denen und dann äh ja kennen wir alle. Solche Situationen und da äh greift dann eben die,
Störerhaftung, ähm die ähm,
Eigentlich laut aktuellem inhaltlichen, wenn man das Gesetz so liest, wie es dort geschrieben steht, dann ähm.
Haften äh Zugangsanbieter nicht,
Ja? Da gibt's also ein Haftungsprivileg für diejenigen, die anderen ähm.
Das ist ja auch Zugänge derzeit schon so.
Das ist derzeit so für Provider, ja? Ähm aber in Ulfs Lesart sagt er im Prinzip,
wenn ich bei mir zu Hause anderen Zugang zum Internet ermögliche, bin ich ja auch ein Zugangsanbieter. Ähm das haben aber eben, hat sich in verschiedenen Gerichtsurteilen ähm.
Nicht durchgesetzt. Diese Interpretation des Gesetzestextes, weshalb Ulf ja schon vor langer Zeit dann oder digitale Gesellschaft, vor langer Zeit schon den Vorschlag gemacht hat, eben,
nochmal das Gesetz zu ergänzen, um auch eine Privatperson kann,
Zugangs ist Zugangsanbieter, ja? Um da das Haftungsprivileg,
ähm der Provider insofern abzuschaffen, dass man diese,
Haftungsausschuss eben für alle äh ermöglicht. Und dann wäre äh die Folge, dass Menschen natürlich sehr viel eher geneigt wären, ein ein offenes, einen offenen WLAN-Zugang einfach zu ermöglichen, wie,
ja die Freifunnker äh sehr gerne tun und ähm man das eben auch einfach so, ne? Machst du noch ein WLAN an, machst du noch ein zweites WLAN auf.
Einfach Straßennetz.
Straßennetz gib ihm, ne? Sollte es natürlich nicht dein eigenes nehmen, wo du deine eigenen Daten durchfunkst, weil du die ja dann unverschlüsselt rumfunken würdest. Ähm
Das heißt, da wär's wärst du also gut beraten ein zweites Netz einfach aufzumachen, dass dann offen ist im anderen
in anderen Segmente, am anderen IP-Adressbereich, der eben in deinen eigenen nicht damit deine jetzt deine ganzen Heimserver und so nicht den dann quasi auf die Straße expostet oder so, aber kann man ja eigentlich ganz gut machen.
Ist auch heutzutage kein großes Problem mehr, so jede Fritzbox kommt so standardmäßig eigentlich mit so einem Gastzugangsnetz und so, das ist äh einfach geklickt und dann macht man ein Passwort aus und fertig ist die.
Genau, die haben das sogar schon mitgeliefert, dass es äh eigentlich sehr schön und das das äh hat auch technisch sehr geringes Risiko, aber ähm leider eben ein hohes juristisches Risiko, weil,
Nach aktueller Rechtsprechung äh wir dann als Privatperson benachteiligt sind und dafür haften würden, der Allgemeinheit oder dafür bestraft würden der Allgemeinheit,
Freude zu machen und.
Deswegen sind wir dann gezwungen, was weiß ich, irgendwie ein VPN dahinter zu knoten, das Ganze in Schweden rauskommen zu lassen oder den ganzen Traffic im Tor zu werfen oder so, um äh um Gutes zu tun. Und das ist natürlich sehr schade,
und jetzt war grade so,
mit Urteilen von des Amts äh Amtsgerichts Hamburg, Amtsgericht Charlottenburg, Landesgericht München ging's so ein bisschen in die Richtung,
zumindest die Situation für Freifunk zu klären, ja? Dass man jetzt nicht sagt, okay, jede Privatperson äh kriegt jetzt einen Haftungsausschuss, aber dass man zumindest die Situation,
Für die Initiative Freifunk mal so ein bisschen klärt. Ja, dass dass man sagt, das ist doch echt mal toll, wenn äh wenn Menschen hingehen,
und kostenlose Infrastruktur äh zum Wohle aller Aufbauen, da möchten wir doch als Gesetzgeber äh denen nicht im Wege stehen, aber weit gefehlt, ich hatte das ja vor einigen Sendungen schon mal erwähnt
Es gibt da natürlich noch andere Interessen und die Interessen sind
einerseits natürlich die, der Verwertungsindustrie, der ja ein relativ stabiles Standbein im Abmahnwesen hat mit Hilfe ihrer
Abmahnkanzleien, wie zum Beispiel Waldorf Frommer, die diesen Prozess automatisiert haben.
Und auch ein stabiles Standbein im äh Regierungs äh Bereich, zum Beispiel im Bundeswirtschaftsministerium mit Dieter Gorny.
Stimmt genau.
Steht mit beiden Beinen fest. Fest im System.
Also Verwertungsindustrie hat ein großes Interesse daran, dass äh das Internetnutzer letztendlich identifizierbar sind oder es zumindest irgendjemanden gibt, an dessen Geldbörse sie dann knabbern können,
und natürlich ähm die äh Firmen, die jetzt Hotspots bauen wollen, also Deutsche Telekom bot Hotspots
Kabel Deutschland baut Hotspots gibt's sicherlich noch viele andere, die sowas machen. Die haben natürlich auch kein Interesse daran, dass äh dass es irgendwie das frei von Kids modern wird und alle nur noch Freifunk machen und wir überall Netz haben, weil sie wollen ja möglichst den Leuten
einmal Internet zu Hause verkaufen.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass sie das jetzt und dass die Freifunk jetzt unbedingt als große Konkurrenz ansehen. Denkst du das?
Nahe.
Sie sehen Freifunk im Moment nicht als große Konkurrenz an, weil die momentane rechtliche Situation diese Freifunnk-Initiative doch sehr stark ausbremst. Ne, weil frei Funk nicht hingehen kann äh und eine,
Einfache, schnelle,
problemlose Variante zur Verfügung stellen kann, wie man garantiert ohne viel Ärger und ohne technischen Aufwand ähm mal eben so ein offenes Netz machen kann.
Natürlich haben sie das, so? Natürlich haben sie da Lösungen für, aber die sind natürlich auch nochmal mit so,
einer der Wege ist eben dann, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, äh in das Freifunk VPN zu kommen, dann routet man einfach nochmal alles durch Freifunk und dadurch ist Freifunk dann eben.
Sozusagen.
Und dann ist durch die Initiative Freifunk dann da diese äh äh das Haft.
Größe der der Teilnehmer oder was.
So und jetzt genau in diese Richtung geht's jetzt so langsam. Die die genaue rechtliche Situation, wie es im Moment steht, ist mir da gar nicht so,
im Detail bekannt, aber ich will auch auf was anderes hinaus. Wenn jetzt auf einmal,
Wenn jetzt das passieren würde, was nämlich ähm sinnvoll wäre, nämlich, dass man sagt, Internet ist Internet und wer anderen Zugang bereitstellt, kann die nicht kontrollieren,
Soll bitte irgendwie da reinkommen, das ist schon zum Wohle aller. Ähm vor allem würde der,
Vorteil für die Gesellschaft und sicherlich auch für den,
für die wirtschaftliche Tätigkeit dieses Landes überwiegen gegenüber den marginal oder Nischeninteressen eben dieser Abmahnindustrie, die dann eventuell ein paar Leute weniger erfolgreich abmahnen könnte,
ähm und gegenüber den kommerziellen Interessen der äh
Netzanbieter, die nämlich sagen wollen, okay, wir verkaufen dir, lieber Tim, einmal hier ähm dein Internet zu Hause,
verkaufen wir dir nochmal eine SIM-Karte fürs Telefon und dann kannst du irgendwie, wenn du rechts unten klickst, kriegst du noch die Hotspot-Flatrate, die kostet dich dann auch nochmal so und so viel. Dann kommst du in unsere Hotspots rein, ne? Oder wenn du keine Hotspot haben willst, dann zahlt dafür, ne? Ähm.
Und außerdem verkaufen wir auch noch dein DSL zu Hause auch noch anderen Leuten auf der Straße als Hotspot noch mit oben drauf.
Ich mache die Telekom das auch, ich weiß, dass andere Internetanbieter.
Auf jeden Fall alles auf dem besten Weg so.
Und dieses Geschäftsmodell, also das hast du zum Beispiel auch in in Frankreich, weiß ich, mache das ähm SFR
die stellen den Leuten halt so 'ne 'ne WLAN-Router mit Gastnetz hin und dieses Gastnetz ist aber dann eben ihr Hotspot teil, ne? Ich bin mir nicht ganz genau so sicher, was ihr ähm Modell dahinter ist. Ich glaube, die sind sogar einfach so fair, dass sie sagen
kommst du auch bei den anderen Leuten in rein, was ja eigentlich was ja nochmal cool wäre, ja? Das wäre so eigentlich dieses Phone.
Modell genau.
Was auch noch im coolen Bereich wäre, aber,
Ähm wir wissen ja, dass die äh dass in Deutschland insbesondere so coole und sharing Sachen äh ungern gesehen sind, wenn ich zumindest irgendwo noch jemand sitzt mit einem großen Sackgelb äh und sein Reibach macht.
Also, sinnvoll wäre es gewesen, die die Rechtssicherheit äh herzustellen, dass man das machen kann und da keinen Ärger für kriegt, aber.
Der jetzige Gesetzesentwurf macht genau das Gegenteil und sorgt dafür, dass Provider weiterhin gar nicht haften,
Also da ändert sich nichts, so deutsche Telekom haftet nicht. Ähm,
Für deinen Internetanschluss. Die hauen dich ja dann auch im Zweifelsfall in die Pfanne. WLAN-Betreiber,
Hingegen sollen nur dann nicht haften, wenn sie zumutbare Maßnahmen ergriffen haben.
Mit anderen Worten, im Vergleich zu der Regelung im Paragraph acht Telemediengesetz, die wir heute haben, gibt's also eine Haftungsverschärfung. Du bist,
nur wenn du zumutbare Maßnahmen erreichst. Was sind denn diese zumutbaren Maßnahmen? Da wird also genannt, ähm äh.
Der ich begehe keine Straftaten.
Nee, da gibt's drei Stufen. Du musst dein dein Netz vom Zugang anderer Nutzer trennen,
Äh äh ähm ausschließen und nur Leute den Leuten den Zugang ermöglichen, die zuvor ein Gewicht haben, keine Rechtsverletzung zu begehen.
Was er für sich genommen schon mal, ja.
Rein private nicht geschäftsmäßige WLAN-Anbieter, das ist explizit einfach nur Freifunk, ja, das.
Kommen nur dann in den Genuss der Haftungsfreistellung, wenn sie außerdem auch die Namen der Nutzerinnen und Nutzer kennen.
Und damit ist dieses Freifunkprojekt kaputt.
Illegal. Ja. Weil da kennt niemand den.
Du kriegst einen kompletten Störerhaftungsfrei äh freistellung, wenn du geschäftsmäßig bist.
Du musst als Privatperson,
die Leute du darfst als Privatperson einfach nicht einfach alle reinlassen und jeden, den du zu Hause in dein Netz lässt, musst du irgendwie, der muss dir äh den musst du aufgeklärt haben oder so, ja? Und wenn du ein,
gemeinnütziger, nicht geschäftsmäßiger, rein privater WLAN-Anbieter bist, dann musst du darüber hinaus,
die Leute registrieren. Und damit werden also private Netzbetreiber,
Nicht-Kommerzielle Netzbetreiber gegenüber gewerblichen schlechter gestellt.
Die Definition eigentlich. Also ab wann ist denn irgendwas.
Gewerblich ist es wahrscheinlich dann, wenn du Geld dafür nimmst.
Also für jede einzelne Dienstleistung oder überhaupt für irgendeine.
Da würde ich vermuten, dass es äh eine mit dieser Wlananschluss in Verbindung stehen. Also da braucht man, glaube ich, jetzt weiß nicht, wo du darauf wo du genau.
Na ja gut, ich meine, die Telekom bietet ja auch hier und da einen kostenlosen Zugang an, wie zum Beispiel in der ersten Klasse der Bahn oder ähm.
Genau, ob die Bahn da nicht vielleicht zum Beispiel die Telekom für bezahlt. Aber genau dafür, genau dafür, genau für solche Fälle ähm,
dass die Telekom ein gewerblicher WLAN-Anbieter ist. Das musst du, glaube ich, nicht,
da musst du keine lange Schrift verfassen um das zu begründen. Und das die Telekom auch ein gewerblicher WLAN-Anbieter im ICE ist,
Ist auch klar, weil sie im Zweifelsfall von der Deutschen Bahn bezahlt wird. Trotzdem möchte die Deutsche Telekom aber in genau dieser Situation, wo sie nämlich,
Ein WLAN oder in der Lounge oder sowas, na ein WLAN anbietet und dir nur so kurz so einen Capture-Unterschied, was ja auch totaler Quatsch ist, genau in der Situation möchte die Deutsche Telekom nämlich nicht verpflichtet sein,
Die Leute ähm,
namentlich zu registrieren, weil das die Nutzung ihrer Dienstleistungen äh unangenehmer machen würde. Und genau diesen Gefallen kriegt sie jetzt auch. Dass sie nämlich sagen kann, du bist äh freigestellt, du bist gewerblich, fertig.
Na gut, aber könnt ihr ja Freifunk auch sagen, okay, wir haben aber auch einen Kunden, der zahlt hier hundert Euro und die anderen äh.
Weißt du doch, dass das so nicht läuft.
Ja, ich weiß ja, dass das noch nicht läuft. Naja.
Das weiß ja, dass das so nicht läuft, weil der Gesetztext genau das sagt, wenn du nicht geschäftsmäßig bist. Freifunk könnte jetzt sagen,
ja, wir sind geschäftsmäßig, weil äh okay, Scheiße, wir sind ein gemeinnütziger Verein. Da können wir schon mal gar nicht mehr irgendwie vernünftig geschäftsmäßig sein und dann müssten sie ja auch im Zweifelsfall ihre Kunden da kennen, ne. Also die Deutsche Telekom,
Hat er jetzt ein ein in dem konkreten Fall einfach offenes WLAN anzubieten,
bevor eine Bevorteilung gegenüber äh dem der Freifunnitiative. Und es ist ganz konkret genau so geschrieben. Das heißt, das Gesetz tut genau das Gegenteil von dem, was behauptet wird.
Und außerdem äh haben wir da noch diesen Passus drin, dass man eben, dass es den Haft die Haftungsumkehr bei Gefahr geeigneten Diensten gibt,
also ähm normalerweise haftest du ja als äh als Plattform, wo andere auch Inhalte reinschreiben können, erst ab Zeitpunkt der Erkenntnis,
Das heißt, wenn ähm äh,
was weiß ich. Wenn jetzt jemand in Logbuch Netzpolitik in den Kommentaren einen urheberrechtlich geschützten Text schreibt, zum Beispiel, sagen wir mal, eine Überschrift von irgendeinem Springerblatt reinschreibt und so
Leistungsschutzrecht und so, ne, dann äh bist du erst dann,
Haftest du es dann, wenn äh dann Kai Diekmann dir eine Mail geschrieben hat und gesagt hat, hier äh Meterebene not welcome, du musst äh diesen, du hast unser Leistungsschutzrecht verletzt oder so, ne? In dem Moment, wo,
haftest du, wenn du dich jetzt dagegen entscheidest, das zu entfernen. Aber du haftest nicht per se. Und für äh,
Gefahr geeignete Dienste? Wollen sie das umkehren und sagen, ey, bei euch.
Geeignete Dienste.
Bei euch ist doch die ganze Zeit nur irgendwie von enorm ist irgendwelche Sachen gepastet, da drehen wir die Haftung um.
Warte mal, jetzt steht das da so drin.
Ja, meinst du, sowas denke ich mir aus oder.
Die vielleicht ja jemand anders, aber es muss ja nicht.
Dass du mir solche, so eine Kreativität äh zutraust,
Freue mich aber ich bin gar nicht so, ich bin eigentlich.
Nein, es hätte ja, es hätte ja auch da nicht drin stehen können, aber eine Definition sein, die irgendjemand anders noch in den Raum gestellt, aber so Gefahr geeignet. Ist das jetzt schon wieder so ein stehender juristischer äh Begriff, Begriff, wo jetzt alle Volljuristen sagen, ach ja hier, Gefahr geeignet, kennen wir doch.
Mir gar nicht sicher, ob du den den haben wir schon äh letzte Mal auch äh verwendet.
Ja, aber nicht auseinander.
Also Cloud-Dienste und File-Hoster äh die sind eben dann als Gefahr geeignete Dienste.
Gefahr geeignete Dienste. Also ich finde diesen Begriff.
Ich gucke mal in den Referentenentwurf.
Gefahr geeignet.
Gefahr. Die Kenntnis von Tatsachen oder Umständen nach Absatz eins,
aus denen die rechtswidrige Handlung oder die Information offensichtlich wird,
vermutet, wenn es sich bei dem angebotenen Dienst um einen besonders Gefahr geneigten Geneigten, sorry. Nicht geeignet, geneigt, sorry.
Geneigt.
Gefahr geneigten Dienst handelt. Ein besonders gefahrgeneigter Dienst liegt in der Regel dann vor wenn, ah die Speicherung oder Verwendung der weit überwiegenden Zahl der gespeicherten Informationen rechtswidrig erfolgt oder B
Der Diensteanbieter durch eigene Maßnahmen gezielt die Gefahr einer rechtsverletzenden Nutzung fördert oder C,
Vom Dienstanbieter veranlassten Werbeauftritten mit der nicht Verfolgbarkeit bei Rechtsverstoßen geworben wird oder D keine Möglichkeit besteht, rechtswidrige Inhalte durch den berechtigten entfernen zu lassen.
Heißt Klartext, du bist Gefahr geneigt, wenn du.
Dadurch aufhältst, dass die überwiegende Zahl der Inhalte, die du bereitstellst, rechtswidrig sind.
Okay, ist aber Freifunk jetzt nicht unbedingt der Fall.
Nein, da geht es auch nicht mehr um äh WLAN-Anbieter, sondern da geht es jetzt um Hosting-Plattformen, um File-Hoster und Cloud-Anbieter. Also Beispiel wäre Pirate Bay, ähm Pace bin,
Wahrscheinlich sogar reddit, wo auch jeder irgendwie reindingern kann. Man könnte jetzt sogar sagen Twitter,
Alles, wo User, Generate Content entsteht, ja? So, wenn A entweder die überwiegende Anzahl der gespeicherten Informationen rechtstätig erfolgt. B.
Du durch eigene Maßnahmen,
gezielt die Gefahr einer Rechtsverletzenden Nutzung förderst. Da wäre das Beispiel zum Beispiel Mega äh Upload oder Mega Punkt com oder wie das jetzt heißt, ne? Weil die sagen,
Ey, bei uns könnt ihr was hochladen, das wird vorher so verschlüsselt, dass wir das gar nicht einsehen können. Und ihr müsst dann quasi den Link mit dem Key weitergeben,
und das eignet sich doch super äh für urheberrechtsverletzende Materialien. Das heißt, da wird ähm,
werden Maßnahmen ergriffen, die es im Prinzip,
Auslegung, vermutlich fördern, dass diese Plattform bevorzugt für illegale Inhalte genutzt wird.
Zäh, du mit der Nichtverfolgbarkeit bei Rechtsverstößen wirbst. Sowas wie ähm wir loggen eure IP-Adressen nicht.
Oder ähm wahrscheinlich könnte man, also nee, von dir veranlasste Werbeauftritte, also quasi du du wirbst damit,
dass du keine Informationen logst und deshalb es bei dir irgendwie eine nicht Verfolgbarkeit gibt.
Also würde jetzt Pace bin sagen, wir loggen nicht, ihr braucht keinen Tor Browser zu nehmen oder so, ne? Oder wenn du D keine Möglichkeit bietest,
Rechtswidrige Inhalte durch den berechtigten entfernen zu lassen. Das ist das, was ähm YouTube da zum Beispiel hat, ne? Die und ich glaube, diese ganzen und so, die haben das ja auch,
bieten quasi den Inhalte äh den den Rechteinhabern quasi direktes Interface, wo sie Inhalte reklamieren können.
YouTube ist ja sogar teilweise äh machen sie es ja auch automatisch, dass sie Musikstücke erkennen. Aber was zum Beispiel manchmal passiert ist, wenn ich irgendwie so bei irgendeiner Fernsehsendung aus privatfernsehern äh Privatfernsehersendern
zu Wort gekommen bin und dann irgendwie ein Mitschnitt der Sendung äh in bei YouTube irgendwie hochlade. Ja Verzeihung.
Dann passiert das äh durchaus mal schnell, dass äh dann irgendwie ein zwei Wochen später so einen Hinweis kommt, was weiß ich, hier, RTL oder was,
hat bemängelt, dass sie das Urheberrecht an diesem Beitrag haben und du den deshalb hier nicht zur Verfügung stellen darfst, haben wir gelöscht. Ne? Kannst du ja auch machen, also diese äh das das steht eben der Musikindustrie und einigen,
großen Rechteverwerter nochmal in in einem anderen, in einer anderen Form zur Verfügung, aber du kannst ja auch ja jetzt so ein YouTube-Video anklickst, kannst du da irgendwie auf den bemängeln Button drücken und sagen, das ist aber meins,
Wenn du das nicht, wenn du diese Möglichkeit nicht äh bietest, dann bist du ein gefahrgeneigter Dienst. Mit anderen Worten, wann immer du.
Irgendwie bereitstellst, musst du dafür sorgen, dass nicht die überwiegende Zahl davon rechtswidrig ist.
Dass du keine Maßnahmen ergreifst, die ähm,
die äh die gezielte Gefahr einer rechtsverletzenden Nutzung fördern, also nicht zum Beispiel nach irgendwas zu irgendwas aufrufen oder so. Oder,
dafür sorgst, dass du keine, dass du nicht die Information sammelst, die du bräuchtest, um die Leute ans Messer zu liefern. Mit anderen Worten, du musst sie,
verfolgen, IP-Adresse loggen, Nutzeraccounts verlangen, was weiß ich.
Aber das tun sie ja doch im ICE halt auch nicht.
Aber die Rede ist jetzt hier von von Cloud und File-Hosting und nicht mehr von WLAN-Zugang.
Es sind zwei unterschiedliche Sachen. Also das eine ist Dienstanbieter, das andere ist Zugangsanbieter und ähm C, du darfst nicht damit werben, dass die nicht Verfolgbarkeit äh stattfindet. Das Krasse ist nämlich.
Nichtverfolgbarkeit. Hat zum Beispiel wirbt ja mit, wenn ich das, ich weiß nicht, ob sie's tun, aber ähm sie,
ähm sind, werden ja gerne genutzt, um die Nichtverfolgbarkeit äh zu erreichen
Also sie sagen, du bist anonym, ja, was man jetzt okay, sie sagen nicht explizit, du kannst bei uns machen, was du willst, aber sie sagen, ey, es ist anonym, wir können dich nicht, wir wir werden und können dich nicht,
Preis geben. Ne? Das könnte man jetzt also streng so auslegen, dass sie damit werben,
dass dass Rechtsverstöße nicht verfolgt werden können, wenn du sie nutzt. Und da sie ja dann auch, ne, so. Das heißt, das wäre dann ein gefahrgeneigter Dienst und bei denen,
wird die Haftung umgekehrt. Das heißt, um jetzt mal wieder, das lässt sich also hier bei C auch auf Zugang äh Münzen, ne, weil ähm,
Predator im Prinzip Zugang bietet. Zu einem.
VPN, was eben in Schweden äh terminiert. Und dann könnte man eben sagen, okay, iPreda, ihr haftet jetzt für alles, was eure Nutzer machen, weil ihr ein Gefahr geneigter Dienst seid und damit wäre Predator eben platt.
Insofern geht's doch nicht nur um Pfeil äh oder kann man das nicht nur auf auf Cloud und Pfeilanbieter äh Fightsharing-Anbieter Münzen, sondern auch auf Zugangsanbieter. Und D eben, wenn du diese Möglichkeit nicht bietest,
Äh die heißt, du musst diese Möglichkeit bieten,
Das heißt, du hast im Prinzip äh schnürt sich ein sehr strenges Korsett, um die äh Menschen, äh die im Internet überhaupt anderen die Möglichkeit geben.
Ähm Inhalte auf ihren Plattformen zu veröffentlichen. Ähm,
In der Begründung steht's dann eben noch zu der Zeit laufen Hotspotbetreiber Gefahr, insbesondere mit urheberrechtlichen Abmahnungen von Rechteinhabern konfrontiert zu werden. Ja, das ist genau die Problem äh Beschreibung. Ähm aber dieser Gesetzesentwurf,
Behauptet, dieses Problem zu lösen, tut aber genau das Gegenteil. Das ist schon wirklich äh ein Skandal. Einmal eben aber, wie gesagt, habe ich, glaube ich, nicht so ober genug rausgestellt. Einmal geht's um diese WLAN-Geschichten. Andererseits geht's um äh,
dienst äh Dienstanbieter. Und das ist schon echt ein ziemlich übler Schritt,
weil das halt bedeutend, also weil unter Umständen damit eben diese Freifunnker äh vollständig unter die Räder geraten. Und das ist echt also da fällt mir auch nichts mehr zu ein, wie man.
Ehrenamtliches Engagement, für freie Zugänge zu Wissen und Netz,
so abstrafen kann,
Für die Partikularinteressen von großen Internet Providern und der äh rechte Verwertungsindustrie. Das ist ein das ist ganz, ganz schlechtes Tennis. Das ist echt richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig dumm.
Ja und das grade in einer Situation, wo wir uns jetzt also in Deutschland mit einer äh,
großen Zahl von Flüchtlingen, die von unserer Bundeskanzlerin freudig begrüßt wurden,
Ähm konfrontiert sehen und deren,
also nicht das einzige Problem ist, aber wenn sie vor allem erstmal hier sind, aber auch natürlich schon auf der Flucht vorher
vor allem auf das Internet angewiesen sind und mit ihren Smartphones einfach ihre Kommunikation äh ihre Information beziehen und zahlreiche Freifunnkprojekte gibt, die einfach sehr gerne,
Flüchtlingsheimen, sonstigen Sammlungsbereichen WLAN bereitstellen wollen,
und sich jetzt sozusagen in eine Grauzone manövriert äh.
Schwarzzone.
Eine Schwarzsonne.
In der Grauzone.
Jetzt ab in die Schwarzzone, ja.
In der Schwarzzone. Es sei denn, äh sie fangt jetzt an, die Leute da irgendwie namentlich zu registrieren, damit sie die irgendwie also das ist halt äh das ist halt wirklich absurd,
Da gibt's halt ein riesiges ehrenamtliches Engagement gerade, ne? Von Freifunk, von Refugees im. Wir haben das äh glaube ich schon erwähnt, oder? In können wir nicht oft genug erwähnen. Es gibt.
Weiß ich nicht, ob wir das erwähnt haben. Ich bin mir da jetzt gerade nicht so äh sicher.
Ja, dann erwähnen wir es nochmal. Es gibt also äh eine seit,
weiß ich seit ich glaube zwölf oder vierzehn Jahren aktives Projekt mit dem Namen Refugees im Incipation, die sich um,
Internetcafes in Geflüchtetenunterkünften bemühen und das ist ein Projekt, was von Geflüchteten,
selber geleitet wird, daher auch dieser
Aspekt immencipation da drin und die auch äh darauf Wert legen, dass ihre Internetcafes eben in ähm Selbstverwaltung dort äh errichtet und äh gepflegt werden und auch Begegnungsstätten sind für die.
Für die Menschen, die dort wohnen. Und ähm seit einiger Zeit gibt es mehrere ähm Mitglieder des äh CCC und des der
der, des Freifunk, der Freifunki Initiative und des Fördervereins freie Netze, die
dafür sorgen möchten, dass dieses Projekt auf finanziell auch auf die nächste auf die nächste Stufe kommt. Ähm,
Und noch viel mehr ähm Geflüchtetenunterkünfte versorgen können, zumal ähm,
Wie ihr jetzt auch nochmal in Deutschland viel mehr davon bekommen werden. Und in einer Woche, vier Tagen und drei Stunden wird dort auch die Fundraising-Kampagne starten,
die wir jetzt einfach mal bei der Gelegenheit verlinken. Ähm,
Und da äh freue ich mich natürlich sehr drauf auf dieses Projekt. Wie ich, glaube ich, schon erwähnt habe, hatten wir auch einen Vortrag beim Camp von Schu, der über dieses Projekt gesprochen hat. Den müssen wir auch noch raussuchen,
Das war echt mal ganz cool. Das hat mich ja sehr ähm sehr gefreut, dass wir sie da hatten,
Und das ist eben jetzt auch so eine so ein Projekt, was da jetzt irgendwie natürlich bedroht wird, ne, weil ähm stell dir jetzt mal vor.
Du bist jetzt gerade aus Syrien geflüchtet, ja? Dann wurdest du vielleicht noch in Ungarn verkloppt,
Ja, dann hast du's irgendwie äh nach Deutschland geschafft, über Österreich oder so. Vielleicht haben dich ähm,
engagierte Bürger mitgenommen in dem in dem Konvoi oder du hast dich in äh hast dich in einen dieser Züge gequält und äh hast ich glaube die Fluchtdauer sehr in der Regel viele Tage,
der Angst und äh.
Wenn's gut läuft, ja.
Der Last auf dich genommen teilweise bis zu irgendwie annähernd vier Wochen, ne? Also die drei Wochen Grenze wird da auch in harten Fällen überschritten. So, du hast die absolute Tortur hinter dir, bist aus der hast dein ganzes Leben hinter dir gelassen, weil du in dem Land, in dem du bist,
Nicht mehr sein kannst, ja, dann kommst du nach Deutschland in eine dieser in der Regel nicht besonders,
ähm nicht besonders liebevoll eingerichteten Unterkünfte. Hass, wenn ihr Pech hast, sogar noch die Arschlöcher draußen vor der Tür stehen,
ja? Und dann sagen sie, ach du willst ins Netz, na dann musst du dich erstmal namentlich registrieren. Weißt du, aus welchen Ländern diese Menschen zu uns kommen? Weißt du, was die dir sagen, wenn du denen sagst, gib mal deinen Namen ein, bevor du hier das Internet nutzt?
Das ist äh hanebüchen. Ähm ich habe übrigens auch noch, ich weiß gar nicht, das hat zu, glaube ich, jetzt in deiner Linkliste gar nicht drin. Es gibt auch noch eine ausführliche äh Kritik,
äh eines äh vom Eco-Beauftragten äh Anwalt, der ein Rechtsgutachten erstellt hat zu diesem WLAN-Gesetzentwurf.
Habe ich, glaube ich, in der Linke, aber sehr geil, schreib's dir noch mal rein.
Hast du das? Von Dieter äh von Dieter Frei.
Ich habe den, vielleicht habe ich's auch nicht drin, weil ich das nur in meinem Maileingang hatte.
Der jetzt, weil ich hatte jetzt hier gerade nochmal diesen Gefahr geneigten Dienst äh hinterher äh recherchier,
und äh er hat auch noch die interessante äh Sichtweise, also was er, weiß nicht, hast du das jetzt gerade eben äh gesagt, dass es ja hier sozusagen auch noch eine Vermutungs,
Regel äh gibt. Also dass sozusagen diese Annahme, dass diese Dienste Gefahr geneigt seien, sei sozusagen ja sozusagen eine Vermutung. Äh kritisiert das als vollkommen Inhaltsbefreit,
und ähm füttern aus, dass äh.
Dass man auf der einen Seite äh also die Formulierung hier ist, wenn ich eine Pseudonyme oder anonyme Nutzung vorschriftsmäßig erlaube, gelte ich sofort als gefahrgeneigter Dienst. Ja, äh.
Es sind Widerspruch zum Datenschutzgesetz.
Genau, ne, wo weil auch im TMG gesagt wird, Anbieter sollen wo immer möglich Datenschutz sparsame Dienste zur Verfügung stellen.
Ein paar weitere äh Kritiken, die ich denke, wir werden das hier einfach auch nochmal anfügen. Ist auf jeden Fall ähm,
Eine sehr knifflige ähm,
Argumentationsführung hier an dieser Stelle, weil es einfach viel mit juristischen Feinheiten zu tun hat. Grundsätzlich müssen wir einfach sagen, wir finden einfach diese Gesetzesinitiative höchst verstörend und es kann einfach nicht sein,
dass äh ein Projekt wie Freifunk oder auch vergleichbare Projekte,
und Dienste ähm hier einfach in die Illegalität gedrängt werden und das äh muss sich ändern.
Ja, also da müssen wir jetzt äh,
Richtig massiv aktiv werden, weil wir ja in der Regel, wir wissen ja, wie das ist mit so äh Gesetzesentwürfen heutzutage, ne, die irgendwie in die achtzig Prozent Mehrheit von äh CDU und CSU irgendwie runtergereicht.
Ja
Da wird es echt doch mal schwer und
noch schwerer ist es, man hätte ja, wenn wenn das jetzt aus der CDU Ecke käme, hätte man ja eventuell irgendwie
versuchen können, äh die SPD dagegen aufzubringen, aber es kommt ja auch noch aus dem BMWI, wo der Sigmar Gabriel drin sitzt
einer unserer drei Internetminister. Ja, das heißt, das ist auch noch eine äh Sozialdemokratennummer. Das heißt, jetzt müssen wir eigentlich mit der CDU dagegen ballern, weil die Sozialdemokraten werden das auf jeden Fall äh durch durch Umfallen. Ähm,
und äh,
jetzt müssen wir wirklich jetzt müssen wir die CDU dazu bringen, so ein beknacktes SPD-Gesetz ähm.
Zu verhindern, was irgendwie.
Absurd ist.
Es ist das sieht echt bitter aus und da muss man jetzt also da bin ich jetzt wirklich äh.
Voller, großer Sorge äh in in dieser Angelegenheit, weil das echt, das wird ähm da kommt sehr viel Gutes und Wichtiges echt unter ekelhafte Räder und das ist echt nicht zu akzeptieren.
Ich denke, wir bleiben da dran an dem Thema. Das wird uns auch äh die nächsten Wochen beschäftigen. Sehr viel mehr können wir jetzt auch glaube ich nicht dazu sagen, oder?
Kommen wir zur weiterer Kritik äh dieses Mal geäußert durch die EU.
EU-Kommission.
Die EU-Kommission, interessanterweise an unserem Lieblingsthema der Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Das ist echt geil. Das ist eigentlich, das ist im Prinzip, das kann man nur mal so, dann lache ich. Dann lache ich, Alter. Hörst du, wie ich lache? Das ist irgendwie also.
Alter, ich lach. Also, nur mal kurz so zurückspulen, also äh wir hatten ja berichtet, äh unsere liebe Bundesregierung
wieder mal dabei äh eine Datenvorratsdatenspeicherung äh zu planen, weil hat ja nicht gereicht, dass das jetzt schon mehrfach äh als verfassungswidrig äh abgelehnt wurde, auch auf EU-Ebene. Nein, man muss es dann halt in der Konsequenz.
Machen, ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch äh konsequent, ne? Weil wenn Geheimdienste versagen, was brauchen wir dann?
Ja, Geheimdienste. Und wenn die Vorratsdatenspeicherung wirklich so schlecht ist, wie immer alle behaupten, dann brauchen wir was?
Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Das ist hier die Logik. Na ja, aber jetzt hat sich die Kommission beschwert.
Allerdings nicht so sehr inhaltlich, sondern mehr so äh bürokratisch.
Weil die hat's, die hat sich nicht unaufgefordert beschwert. Du musst ähm wenn du ein, wenn du als EU-Mitglied einen.
Ein Gesetz machst, was den Markt,
in diesem Ausmaß betrifft, musst du das im Rahmen eines Notifizierungsverfahrens,
Kommission vorlegen, der EU-Kommission. Und dann sagst du und dann ist dieses Gesetz steht dann eben äh zur den Mitgliedsstaaten zum Kommentar. Ja? Und wie wir ja,
Immer wieder äh Wissen, betonen und wiederholen. Der EU geht's immer um die Harmonisierung des Marktes. Verzeihung. Harmonitarisierung des Marktes.
Das heißt, ne, da kommen wir da, also wir erinnern uns an so Sachen, irgendwie ab einem gewissen Projektvolumen müssen Aufträge EU-weit ausgeschrieben werden, ähm all solche Dinge, ja?
Und deswegen hat also wurde jetzt quasi der der Gesetzesentwurf für die deutsche
für den deutschen zweiten Anlauf zuvor, Seitenspeicherung der EU Kommission vorgelegt, wo ihn dann die EU-Kommissarin für Binnenmarkt, Industrie und Unternehmertum,
sich angeschaut hat und dann eine Stellungnahme dazu verfasst hat. Die gute Frau heißt Bienkowska.
Dies schreibt aber die sagt direkt noch dazu aus dem ganzen politischen Hickhack
um äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung yay und so, da will ich mich erstmal ganz raushalten. Ich betrachte das hier in meiner Rolle als äh Kommissarin für Binnenmarkt. Und da sagt sie
Na ja, in unserem Binnenmarkt haben wir ja eine Dienstleistungsfreiheit,
und es ist wirklich supergeil, ist super geil.
Und sagt, finanzielle Benachteiligungen und Einschränkungen in diesem Binnenmarkt.
Soll ich ja vermeiden, will die EU vermeiden,
Deshalb sind solche, also finanzielle Benachteiligungen von anderen Staaten, ja? Sind nur dann zulässig,
Wenn sie notwendig und angemessen zum Schutz spezifischer öffentlicher Interessen sind. Nur dann kannst du deinen Markt einschränken auf Deutschland.
Den EU-Mitgliedsstaat aus dem du kommst. Und.
In diesen Gesetzesentwurf zur steht geschrieben die Datenspeicherung muss in Deutschland stattfinden. Das heißt du schließt,
Du verschließt dich dem europäischen Markt, weil diejenigen, die anderen Diensteanbieter, die jetzt vielleicht auf dem deutschen Markt äh konkurrieren,
Und ihre Server aber woanders stehen haben, werden dann gezwungen, Daten, Vorratsdatenspeicherungszentren in Deutschland zu errichten. Das heißt, die werden gegenüber deinen deutschen Marktteilnehmern ähm.
Äh benachteiligt.
Die Bundesregierung sagt, das ist notwendig, um die grundrechtlichen Erfordernisse des Datenschutzes und der Datensicherheit zu gewährleisten,
Die gespeicherten Vorratsdaten wirksam vom Missbrauch sowie vor jedem unberechtigten Zugang und jeder unberechtigten Nutzung zu schützen.
Und das durch eine unabhängige Stelle zeitnah und effizient überwachen zu können, würde man ja meinen, leuchtet erstmal ein, wenn wir jetzt nämlich unsere Vorratsdatenspeicherung in einem unserer anderen Freunde in der EU,
befreundeten Staaten der EU zum Beispiel in Griechenland, ne, die sind uns ja, die sind Deutschland ja sehr wohlgesonnen.
Oder in England.
Oder in England, ja, GCAQ nimmt sie gern, ja? Könnte man auch machen, ne. Die haben vor allem würden die bei einer öffentlichen Ausschreibung sicherlich das bessere Angebot machen.
Das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, sehr kompetitiver Markt, sehr kompetent.
So und dann sagt die äh die äh EU-Kommissarin, nun bei dieser Argumentation,
Es gibt keine zusätzliche Sicherheit durch eine Speicherung in Deutschland. Von der IT sind die genauso unsicher in jedem anderen Land.
So ist was dran.
Zweitens, zweitens, es gibt eine EU-Datenschutzrichtlinie von neunzehnhundertfünfundneunzig,
und die hat die Sicherheitsanforderung bei Datenspeicherung harmonistarisiert? Also,
haben alle EU-Staaten das gleiche Niveau, beziehungsweise können es leisten im Rahmen dieser Richtlinie. Das heißt, Datenschutz und Datensicherheit ist in jedem EU Staat gewährleistet.
Einfach per Aklamation, weil ist so, steht ja auf Papier und.
Die müssen sich an die Richtlinie halten.
So sein, ist klar, macht ja auch jeder.
Ist der Markt eben schon harmonisarisiert.
Und dann das zweite Argument oder der der zweite Teil der Argumentation der Bundesregierung ist ja okay. Wir wollen, nur dadurch können wir sie wirksam vor Missbrauch schützen,
und wir können diesen Schutz auch durch eine unabhängige Stelle zeitnah und effizient überwachen in Deutschland. Man sagt sie nö, Anforderungen, die ihr,
im Rahmen eurer äh Dienstleistung äh stellt, können EU weit vorgeschrieben und kontrolliert werden, da die anderen EU-Aufsichtsbehörden kooperieren müssen.
Das ist echt super.
Das heißt die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist in Gefahr, weil sie vorsieht, die Daten nur in Deutschland zu speichern,
weil das eben eine Benachteiligung der Marktteilen der unserer der unser europäischen Freunde ist auf diesem Binnenmarkt ähm.
Geil, jetzt sehe ich schon irgendwie.
Und dann sagt sie, würde Deutschland das Gesetz so verabschieden, könnte die Kommission mahnen und das Ganze vor dem EGH landen.
Weiterhin schreibt sie dann.
Also europäischen Gerichtshof. Ja. Mhm.
Weiterhin schreibt sie dann, okay, äh obwohl das ja eigentlich nicht unbedingt ihre ähm,
ihr Thema ist und sie sich ja einig aus dem politischen Hickhack raushalten möchte
Würde sie aber dann doch mal ganz gerne anmerken, dass sie doch dann harsche Zweifel an der Grundrechtskompatibilität dieses Gesetzesentwurfs hat. Nämlich.
Also sie bezieht sich auf das Grundrecht, nicht etwa auf europäische Verfassungsgebung. Nee. Okay. Das ist, sie würde.
Dass es sie würde sehr gerne mal faktische Elemente und Nachweise sehen, die die Speicher da dauern, begründen, denn es wird ja gesagt, Look äh Location-Daten,
speichern wir für vier Wochen und alles andere für zehn. Da sagt sie, warum?
Warum nicht? Drei oder fünf Wochen? Warum nicht neun oder elf? Warum nicht vielleicht auch nur eine? So, habt ihr euch da irgendwas bei gedacht?
Zeig doch mal, faktische Elemente und Nachweise, die zeigen, dass genau diese Dauern notwendig sind und nicht länger oder kürzer gemacht werden kann.
Dann sagt sie natürlich,
Die gesamte Notwendigkeit von Speicherung ist nicht belegt, die Verhältnismäßigkeit ist nicht belegt und wahrscheinlich so oder so nicht gegeben.
Und äh dann sagt sie,
ähm dass es keine Einschränkung auf den unbedingt benötigten Umfang gibt, weil Straftaten von erheblichem Umfang nicht definiert ist. Ja, sie sagt also, ihr sagt ja gar nicht,
Ihr definiert nicht die Straftaten und deswegen ist irgendwie unklar ähm,
in welchem Umfang auch die Auswertung dieser Daten geschehen wird. Und zuletzt sagt sie, wie wollt ihr das denn klären? Äh wie wollt ihr das denn regeln mit den Berufsgeheimnisträgern? Also ähm Anwälte, Journalisten, Pfarrer,
gewinnt noch. Ähm ich weiß gar nicht, ob nee, Journalisten sind auch gar keine Berufsgeheimnisträger, ne, die die äh nur wenige Journalisten sind, Berufsgeheimnisträger.
Ähm weil da ähm ist wird's ja so gemacht, dass man ähm,
dass man deren Daten trotzdem speichert und nur beim Abruf der Daten eben die,
Deren Privileg äh zur äh zur Wirkung kommen lässt. Und dann sagt er, es kann sich irgendwie auch nicht vorstellen, äh wie das jetzt irgendwie in Ordnung sein soll, ne.
Und da hat die Bundesregierung gesagt, jo äh Arsch lecken, wir werden das Gesetz trotzdem machen und dann hat's EU-Kommission gesagt, ja okay, ich glaube, wir werden auch nicht klagen.
So scheint er ihrem Widerstand zu sein. Ähm.
Aber wir wollen's ja mal aber gesagt haben.
Wollen's mal gesagt haben. Also ich ich meine, stell dir mal vor, stell dir jetzt nur mal vor Deutschland führt die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ein.
Und dann kommt die äh EU-Kommission und sagt, ey Freunde, die Daten müsst ihr aber auch irgendwie woanders speichern lassen,
Und dann müssen sind die werden sie vom EuGH dazu gezwungen, die deutschen Vorratsdaten auch in Europa speichern lassen, speichern zu lassen,
Und dann gibt's auf einmal so einen britischen Dienstleister, der sagt.
Ein unschlagbar günstiges Angebot.
Wir verwalten das für euch. Das doch mal aus,
Outsourcing. Kennst du's? Voll geil. Ist super. Du sourct das aus, ne und dann sparst du Geld, weil und er hat nämlich der Jan Korte mal angefragt mit einer kleinen Anfrage der Linkspartei. Wie sind denn so die Kosten,
die wir jetzt äh wie wir unserer Industrie äh dadurch jetzt aufbürden. Wie schätzt ihr die denn ein und wer zahlt die denn,
Da kam die Antwort, die ersten Investitionskosten, also Antwort des äh Bundesministeriums für Justiz,
Das heißt, erste Investitionskosten ist nur die Anschaffung von Hardware. Ja, und irgendwie in Gang bringen von Hardware, die den ganzen Mist speichert.
Und Software wahrscheinlich. Systeme halt.
Ja, äh genau. Schätzt das BMJ auf zweihundertsechzig Millionen,
Allerdings kann man schon sagen, andere wie der Eco schätzen als eher auf sechshundert Millionen. Und kleinere Unternehmen.
Die sich das nicht leisten können, werden entschädigt vom von der Bundesregierung wegen unbilliger Härte,
und bei größeren Unternehmen geht man davon aus, dass die das wie alle ihre anderen Kosten natürlich einpreisen. Das heißt, wir können die Scheiße auch noch selber bezahlen.
Und dann wäre doch wirklich es großartig, wenn wir da vielleicht einen britischen äh outsourcing Partner hätten,
da vertrauensvoll im Rahmen der europäischen,
Gesetzgebung und Richtlinien mit unseren Providern zusammenarbeitet und sie darf von der Würde der sechshundert Millionen Euro, die sie uns irgendwo aus der Tasche ziehen müssen, befreit.
Ähm sodass das für uns das Internet schön billig bleibt. Das ist natürlich jetzt äh.
Aber so ist die Argumentation scheint die EU Kommission darauf zu blicken.
Und ich muss sagen, ich finde es nur noch absurd, dass man sich über solche Dinge.
Hier austauscht. Und ich finde natürlich die der diese Anfrage ähm
Der Linken ist natürlich, der ist natürlich der Hammer, was die da antworten, ne? Also ich mein, war natürlich auch klar, da hätte man jetzt es ist nur schön, dass sie es auch nochmal selber geschrieben haben, ist klar, dass das äh dass die äh dass das BMJ den Mist nicht bezahlt, das machen wir.
Na, wer zahlt denn diese ganze Entschädigung dann letzten Endes? Welches? Na, an die kleinen Unternehmen in Deutschland, bei der.
Na, das wird dann ähm, das wird dann, das wird dann eben vom, vom Bund kommen.
Unbilliger Härte, wenn jetzt ein kleiner E-Mail-Provider bist, nicht so viel Geld hast, kannst du dir das nicht leisten, dann werden sie eben sagen, das kannst du ja auch nicht machen, ne, dass du kleine benachteiligst und diese Kosten werden ja nur zu einem gewissen Maß skalieren
ne? Grade bei kleinen Unternehmen hast du wahrscheinlich dann auch nochmal ja bei kleinen Anbietern verhältnismäßig kleine Anbietern. Das ist natürlich nochmal äh nicht nur
denn die Hardware ist natürlich dann nicht so teuer, wie bei großen, aber dafür hast du eventuell nochmal sehr viel individuellere Lösungen, die du da bauen musst. Und dieser Programmier und Projektplanungsaufwand, den hast du natürlich ähm.
Ohnehin
und der ist wahrscheinlich auch nochmal sehr viel höher, als jetzt das bisschen Hardware, was da hinstellt. Und das wäre ja eben unbillige Härte und deswegen kriegst du da äh von Vater Staat äh Förderung.
Ich schlage hier gerade mal den Begriff unbillige Härte nach, das ist halt auch wieder so ein juristischer Begriff, ne. In einigen Bereichen des öffentlichen Rechts liegt dann eine unbillige Härte vor, wenn den Antragsteller nur ein geringes Verschulden trifft,
und die Folgen der an sich erfolgenden Ablehnung für den erheblich sind.
Hier geht's natürlich um eine Rechtsauseinandersetzung, aber mal übertragen auf diesen Fall heißt das einfach hier könnte er ja nichts für, dass ihr hier alles speichern müsst, kriegt er Geld.
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an äh die den Nichtraucherschutz, wo man gesagt hat, okay ähm.
Äh wenn die Kneipen zwei Räume haben und der eine Raum nicht vom Personal,
Betreten werden muss, dann können die einen Raucherraum haben. Und dann haben die eine Raumkneipen,
Äh ja gesagt, ey Moment mal, das ist ja dann, ne, ein Vorteil der mehrere Umkneipen und äh ja, echt okay. Ich glaube, das ist äh lief auf anderer Ebene, aber so ungefähr, äh muss man sich das vorstellen, ne? Es war ja dann.
Gab's dann eine Ausgleich.
Ich glaube, in einigen Bundesländern äh konntest du, konntest du dann auf äh konntest du halt einen Raum Raucherkneipen wieder machen, weil die ja sonst.
In Berlin auch so. Na ja, gut, ich.
Womit dann der der gesamte Nichtraucherschutz wieder komplett im Arsch war.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so ganz sicher, ob jetzt Nichtraucherschutzgesetz und äh Forstdatenspeicherung jetzt hier gut zusammenpasst. Aber um das jetzt vielleicht mal ein bisschen äh zusammenzufassen, es gibt eine interessante Kritik,
ja, interessanterweise auch aus dem Marktgeschehen heraus und äh ich weiß ja nicht genau.
Die Kommission klagt nicht, heißt das, dass es niemand anders klagen kann, also äh muss das unbedingt die Kommission machen. Ich finde das schon bemerkenswert,
Was man sich hier an der Stelle auch gar keine Gedanken darüber gemacht hat. Ähm oder vielleicht hat man sich darüber Gedanken gemacht, aber zumindest wird das jetzt halt weitgehend erstmal äh ignoriert,
Aber vielleicht durchaus irgendwann in dieser Situation sind, dass so eine Vorratsdatensprechung, wenn sie denn dann mal eingeführt ist,
ja, sagen wir mal, die setzen das jetzt um und die Kommission so, oh, wir haben nix gesehen, so, aber irgendwann ändern sich halt mal die Vorzeichen und dann so, ja, übrigens, äh, das müsst ihr aber jetzt mal ausschreiben, so.
Da darf sich hier auch unlimited storage äh LTD äh dran beteiligen so ja oder es wird irgendeine andere äh Firma, die das dann halt outsourct nach Unlimited Storage LTD, weil dürfen sie ja.
Also ich glaube, dass diese Outsourcing-Gedanke, dass dass es ja eher noch so ein Scherz, ne. Hoffe ich.
Von wem jetzt von mir?
Ja, ich bin mal gespannt, ja. Also, das ist, ich finde das, ich finde das auf jeden Fall echt witzig, wieder argumentiert wird.
Und ich ich weiß auch nicht genau, also ich stelle mir jetzt gerade mal vor, in welchem also eigentlich soll die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ja bei den Providern geschehen, ne? Und nicht bei äh nicht zentral.
Nicht durch den Staat, weil der ist ja gar nicht so böse. Der will das ja nur haben, wenn wenn's wirklich benötigt wird.
Ja. Ja, Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh.
Eigentlich schon alles dazu gesagt. Wir werden aber auch weiterhin alles dazu sagen. Das bringt uns zu Kurzbildung.
Genau. Wir haben ja in der Folge einhundertfünfzig mit Andre schon äh ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, dass die Bundeswehr jetzt äh den Cyberraum als vierte Dimension
beglücken möchte mit ihrer Wirkmacht und,
Jetzt hat es eine jetzt wurde es, wurde eine strategische Leitlinie Cyberverteidigung ähm,
Im Geschäftsbereich, Bundesministerium für Verteidigung, die konzeptionellen Grundlagen dafür beschaffen. Schon heute beschäftigt die Bundeswehr fünfzehntausend Soldaten,
und zivile Mitarbeiter im Cyber und Informationsbereich, ja? Ähm klar, die haben jetzt natürlich auch mit Computern zu tun,
und die Bundeswehr, ne, wir wissen ja, die ist ja nur zu unserer Verteidigung da, ähm es sei denn,
Wir müssen uns am Hindukusch verteidigen. Ähm.
Und da möchte sie natürlich diesen Schutz jetzt auch den Daten und Infrastrukturen ähm zukommen lassen.
Und äh Ursula von der Leyen hat aber dann betont, dass sie sich ausdrücklich auf defensive Cyber-Fähigkeiten konzentriert, dass äh,
Stimmt allerdings nicht unbedingt, denn die Bundeswehr hat schon seit Jahren auch eine Abteilung Cyberattacke. Das ist das Kommando strategische Aufklärung
in der in Rheinbach, in der Tombokkaserne, bei Bonn, wo sechzig Informatiker äh stationiert sind und äh Angriffe auf fremde Netzwerke trainieren.
Und was ich dann sehr interessant fand, ist dass der Bitcom, der Brancheverband Bitcom ähm,
Daneben steht und das irgendwie auch noch toll findet und sagt, ja, also eine neue Organisationsstruktur kann nur der erste Schritt sein. Wir müssen jetzt hier erstmal direkt ein Cyber-Kommando äh aufbauen und mehr Haushaltsmittel zur Verfügung bekommen. Und.
Jetzt kommt natürlich, worum geht's denen? Worum geht's den Tim? Geld verdienen beim Einkauf von Hard und Software,
so der Bitcom möge man doch bitte in Zukunft die schnelle technische Entwicklung im IT-Bereichen mit kürzeren Beschaffungszyklen äh,
der, der, der schnellen Entwicklung im IT-Bereich mit kürzeren Beschaffungszyklen ähm Rechnung tragen, ne? Die Beschaffungszyklen,
sind natürlich,
Die Hard- und Software wird natürlich für die Bundeswehr äh möglichst in Deutschland gekauft, solange die EU-Kommission da nicht.
Sich mal zu äußern.
Dadurch äh protestiert. Und es wäre natürlich,
Sagt der Bitcom, äh notwendig, sich besser mit der NATO und der EU zu koordinieren,
und äh eine große Herausforderung ist für die Bundeswehr, die Gewinnung von ausreichend vielen IT-Experten
Und natürlich sollte die Bundeswehr doch bitte strategisch mit Wirtschaft äh mit der Wirtschaft zusammenarbeiten, damit da Erfahrung und Know-How ausgetauscht werden können. Das heißt, die die Bundeswehr marschiert in den Cyber
und ähm die Branchen der Branchenverband steht daneben und freut's
freut sich, schreibt 'ne Pressemitteilung mit dem Titel, wir begrüßen das neue Cyberkommando der Bundeswehr.
Ja, jetzt geil, jetzt geil, krieg auch mit Bits. Das ist doch für Bitcom genau das Richtig.
Da haben wir noch in den in den in den so ein so ein Video verlinkt, wo jetzt wo jetzt die Bundeswehr auch schon äh Propagandavideos macht zum Cyber,
Und irgendwie als eines der Probleme, äh die unsere Gesellschaft grade hat, die äh die Bundeswehr jetzt lösen wird, ist, dass äh Nondom ist irgendwie NPD äh Mitglieder äh Daten ähm
Öffentlich zu wenig gemacht hat.
Ja, es ist fantastisch.
Da muss jetzt die Bundeswehr hin.
Das ist echt ein großes Problem, nicht, dass die da unsere ganzen Nazis hier aufdecken.
Ja, fand ich sehr äh fand ich's,
sowieso irgendwie ein sehr komisches, das war so ein super komisches Video. Wenn irgend so ein heißer Redakteur, äh wo ich auch nicht weiß, warum sitzt er, wieso macht sich warum gibt sich
eine warum darf jemand bei Heise schreiben, der sich für Propaganda-Videos, der äh der Bundeswehr hergibt?
Oder anders ausgedrückt, warum gibt sich jemand, der bei Heise schreibt für Bundeswehrpropaganda-Videos her? Ja, ist mir unbegreiflich. Ja.
Ja, ist mir unbegreiflich. Ähm und dann irgendwie noch so ein ähm,
irgendso ein Forscher da, der irgendwie zeigt, wie er ein Auto aufmacht. Sehe ich jetzt auch nicht genau. Also auch so.
Voll die Gefahr.
Voll die Gefahr, ey, die die nehmen uns die Autos weg, ne, der Deutsche und sein Auto. Ich, also ich, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie dieses Video zustande gekommen ist. Das äh.
Hacker äh Hacker mit Maske zwei null, das ist halt einfach so. Man muss jetzt hier irgendwie äh den Feind äh an allen Ebenen und Enden, die man jetzt natürlich auch vollkommen absurd, gerade das mit dem Auto. Ja, ich meine, könnte man mal eher dann zur,
zur Automobilindustrie geht und sagen, wollt ihr nicht mal hier eure eure Sicherheitstechnik ordentlich in den Griff kriegen.
Äh ja also und dann labern sie da irgendwie einen und,
Also da wird irgendwie nur so, ja hier und dein Auto nehmen sie dir weg und äh und hier ist auch ein Hacker und dann und dann am Ende Bundeswehr. Also das
Ey, meine Güte, ist das das ist halt echt einfach so ein Propaganda-Video, damit die Leute das jetzt sehen und denken so
oh krass, die können mein Auto klauen. Na dann will ich aber mal die Bundeswehr da haben, ne. Dass dein Auto meistens in Deutschland rumsteht und du die Bundeswehr nicht im Inneren haben willst und,
der Hersteller von deinem Auto schuld ist, dass er da irgendwie so eine dämliche äh Technik ähm eingebaut hat, die inzwischen halt irgend so ein,
Hochschultyp da irgendwie nachspielen kann, die die Replay Attacke. Also wie dem auch sei, gucken,
Und genau hingucken und dann sich mal überlegen, auf welchem niederträchtigen Niveau diese Propaganda da jetzt läuft. So, das ist auch wirklich ähm,
Ja, ich wollte mich eigentlich nicht so viel aufregen.
Ja, ich wollte das auch gerade äh etwas äh kritisieren, äh weil
das müssen wir jetzt, glaube ich, auch gar nicht weiter äh kommentieren. Auf jeden Fall, es wird hier äh fleißig äh hyperventiliert und alle freuen sich darüber, dass jetzt halt auch äh
der Cyber äh Einzug äh hält und der Bitcom applaudiert natürlich besonders, äh weil der schon immer gerne mal bei Kriegsgeschäft mitmachen wollte und,
können sie halt jetzt mal auch mit ihren digitalen Sachen, also nicht, dass das jetzt schon überhaupt nicht der Fall war, aber jetzt eben dann auch nochmal so richtig und dann bitteschön auch mit
den deutschen mit der deutschen Industrie. Ich meine, da können wir uns jetzt groß drüber aufregen, aber mal ehrlich, überraschen tut dich das jetzt doch nicht, oder?
Ja, aber weißt du, man muss wenigstens immer überrascht tun.
Guten, dann tun wir jetzt mal überrascht.
Wenn ich.
Okay äh auch sehr überrascht bin ich äh, dass.
Beim Dennis A oder auch BND oder hier äh Untersuchungsausschuss des Bundestages. Kein Reformbedarf gesehen wird. Das ist auch sehr überraschend.
Ja, das sagt der äh Günther Heiß, nicht der nicht der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, aber Günther heißt, äh als Gast im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss
der Geheimdienst Koordinator im Bundeskanzleramt,
ähm der dann mal so gefragt wurde, wie er denn jetzt so gerade auf die Lage äh im Allgemeinen blickt und äh was äh was werden wir tun? Was werden Sie tun? Da hat er gesagt, ja er könnte sich vorstellen, dass man noch ein paar klarstellende Regeln ins BND-Gesetz äh schreibt
aber ähm.
Insgesamt lief ja alles nach Plan. Das wäre ja schon alles in Ordnung. Und äh wird dann zitiert mit wir sind der abgestimmten Meinung, dass es,
Dass eine konkrete Eingriffsbefugnis rechtlich nicht erforderlich ist. Ähm da geht es um,
die ähm durch die Massen das Massen abhören des BND, ne? Denn die Generalklausel im BND-Gesetz reiche ja auch für so weit gefasste Maßnahmen aus. Dass sie Routineverkehre abhören,
ähm wäre jetzt nicht ein Grundrechtseingriff.
Und das Kanzleramt würde sich aber in seiner Güte dem Wunsch des G zehn Gremiums,
ohne Anerkennung einer Rechtspflicht ähm beugen oder sich diesen Wunsch zu Herzen nehmen,
dass man bei derlei Praktiken künftig dann doch mal das Gezien informieren würde,
auch wenn man der Meinung ist, dass dazu keine Rechtspflicht besteht. Das muss der das muss er natürlich so sagen, weil wenn sie,
anerkennen würden, dass es da eine Rechtspflicht schon immer gegeben hat, dann müssten sie eben auch zugeben, dass sie genau dieses äh Gesetz,
in den vergangenen Jahren und Jahrzehnten immer wieder verletzt haben
und deswegen sagte er, wir haben da keine Rechtspflicht. Die Generalklause im BND Gesetz äh lässt uns lässt zu, dass wir das tun, aber wir werden dann in Zukunft,
ähm habt ihr unser Wort,
Dass wir euch informieren, auch wenn wir euch nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass wir dazu rechtlich nicht verpflichtet sind.
Und außerdem so der gute Herr heiß, äh sei die Bundesregierung für eine transparentere Kontrolle und eine saubere Regelung generell offen,
aber im Großen und Ganzen deute ja jetzt nichts darauf hin, dass irgendwo rechtswidrige Zustände herrschen würden.
Da fällt einem doch nichts mehr ein. Ja, das, was.
Hat er das gesagt? Ich habe dann du ziehst mit dem Schlammmassel. Nicht jeder Schlama.
Weil das habe ich jetzt nicht zitiert, weil's nicht in äh Anführungszeichen ist, aber der den Begriff wird sicherlich der äh Redakteur äh sich da jetzt nicht äh ausgedacht haben. Insofern wird er es wahrscheinlich gesagt haben.
So nach dem Motto, ja natürlich sitzen wir bis zum Hals in Scheiße, aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass es stinkt. Währenddessen.
Währenddessen ähm haben Grüne und Linke jetzt äh,
auf Einsicht in die Selektorenliste geklagt, also Selektorenliste jene Selektoren, die der BND in seinen äh Abgefangenendaten zum Einsatz gebracht hat und die Ergebnisse der NSA gegeben hat.
Da, wo er nämlich auch die Sektoren her hatte, ja, die NSA hat ja quasi den BND die Selektoren gegeben,
Ähm der BND hat die Selektoren zur Anwendung gebracht und die Ergebnisse der NSA zurückgegeben und genau in diesen Selektoren fand sich ja irgendwie massiv ähm.
Innereuropäische Ziele. Das heißt, der BND hat gegen,
Äh wahrscheinlich sich selbst und Europa äh oder gegen Deutschland und europäische Nachbarstaaten spioniert und die Ergebnisse der NSA gegeben. Wir vergessen das immer mal wieder. Ja,
und.
Gegen sich selbst hat sich sozusagen selbst abgehört.
Nein, nicht nicht sich selbst, aber das Land.
Sein. Ich meine, wenn sich die Selektoren so schlecht geprüft haben, dann kann das auch durchaus sein, dass sie sich selbst abgehört.
Sagen wir mal das Land, das den größten Teil seines Budgets stellt. Und äh.
Und äh.
Die Grünen und also Grüne und Linke sagen jetzt, dass äh der Untersuchungsausschuss natürlich hier äh,
Recht auf Aktenvorlage hat und dieses gerne geltend machen würde, indem man äh den äh Untersuchungsausschussmitgliedern
Einblick in diese Selektorenliste gibt. Äh aber die Bundesregierung entgegnet dem ja. Na, die USA erlauben uns das nicht,
Ähm und deswegen wird der Graulich, den wir jetzt grade als Sonder äh Berichterstatter dahingeschickt haben, im Detail auch nicht berichten dürfen,
Ja, der graulich,
ein bisschen die technische Expertise, aber ist nicht so schlimm, weil der die technische Expertise steuern ja die BND-Mitarbeiter bei, die ihm helfen.
Das äh zu lesen.
Oh Gott.
Dass die BND-Mitarbeiter hier ja die im Prinzip die Beschuldigten sind, ja,
Also so was hast du noch nicht gesehen und also die die die Bundesregierung hängt also das Staatswohl von
USA und Deutschland hier in die Waagschale und sagt, sowohl unser Staatswohl als auch das der USA würde hier verletzt werden, wenn rauskommt, wen wir, gegen wen wir in Europa alles spioniert haben für die Amis,
Deswegen könntet können wir das nicht haben und außerdem wäre das ja auch,
ganz kurz, wenn ich noch ganz kurz das ausführen darf. Das muss man sich nämlich hier noch auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Wenn der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss,
Diese Selektorenliste einsehen dürfte.
Wäre die vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit zwischen BND und NSA in Gefahr. Die vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit
in der die NSA irgendwie eine so große Anzahl von Selektoren
dem BND gegeben hat, dass sich da drunter irgendwie eine fünf, sechs, fünf bis sechsstellige Anzahl von Spionagezielen in Europa verborgen hat, die der BND noch nicht mal gefunden hat,
eine so, so schöne, vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit, die wollen wir ja nicht gefährden, sagt die Bundesregierung. Also eigentlich genau das, was hier untersucht.
Genau, das wollte ich nämlich auch grad sagen. Das ist doch so exakt mal genau das, worum's hier geht. Das zu untersuchen.
Wir können, wir müssen euch leider daran hindern, das zu untersuchen, diesen unglaublichen Vertrauensbruch der NSA gegenüber dem BND,
Des BND gegenüber ganz Europas, weil sonst würden wir diese wunderbare, vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit gefährden.
Das ist, ich absurd.
Ist einfach nur absurd.
Los, weiter, Kurzmeldung.
Ja, Kurzmeldung. Ja, Bundestags hat jetzt die, die. Äh, wir hatten ja ähm,
den äh vor einigen Wochen diese schöne Situation, dass dann da die IT-Systeme irgendwie neu aufgesetzt wurden. Da mussten alle ein neues Passwort geben und so, ne? Und,
Jetzt haben sie aber endlich gecheckt,
Also das ist wohl, ich glaube, das war eigentlich schon immer klar, aber es war jetzt irgendwie, jetzt ist es auch offiziell der Angriff auf den Bundestag, erfolgte durch eine E-Mail,
die als Nachricht von der UNO getarnt war und,
Im Betreff dieser E-Mail äh ging es dann wohl äh um den Ukraine-Konflikt
war der war der Begriff Betreff und da war dann ein Link
Äh zu demselben Thema auf ein United Nation News Bulitan,
Und wenn man auf diesen Link geklickt hat, gelangte man eben zu einer Internetseite, die dann äh die Rechnerinfizierte, ne,
Vermutlich offenbar ähm,
Wohl ein äh Drive-By Explode, also irgendein PDF oder vielleicht auch eine Extradatei, wo man dann noch darauf gesetzt hat, dass die dann jemand noch ausführt oder so. Ähm das wird hier nicht weiter bekannt gegeben, aber jetzt.
Excel-Dateien dazu wirklich, dass das den Bundestag Mailserver passiert hätte?
Nee, ist ja ähm eine E-Mail mit einem Link,
Du klickst halt dann auf den Link ähm und das ist so kommst du eigentlich an allem vorbei, ne? Aber ich würde auch nicht wenn ich jetzt hier äh ein,
informierte informiert raten müsste, würde ich damit rechnen, dass würde ich schätzen, dass es hier wahrscheinlich dann sich um Flash Explode gehandelt hat ähm oder um irgend so ein PDF-Explode, weil die eben auch die billigsten sind
und äh oder so häufig sind, dass man die ähm,
Nicht teuer kaufen muss und relativ zielrichtig zum Einsatz bringen kann. Ähm.
Der Witz ist aber, diese E-Mail befindet sich jetzt immer noch in den Postfächern der Abgeordneten. Ähm.
Abgeordneter. Ja. Das Thema ist ja immer noch aktuell.
Die natürlich da jetzt auch sagen, ey, was ist das denn hier für eine Desinfektion, wenn diese Angreifer-E-Mail immer noch in unseren ähm in unserem Postfach ist.
Nun gut, ihr habt ja jetzt,
liebe Bundestagsabgeordneten, eine dicke äh Websperre. Ich würde hoffen, dass in der in der Liste der hunderttausend Webseiten, die euer äh Paar, die euch jetzt gesperrt sind, sich dann wahrscheinlich auch jene Seite,
befindet, wo ihr euch die ursprüngliche Trojanerinfektion eingefangen habt. Gleichzeitig glaube ich, wäre diese E-Mail aus euren Postfächern gelöscht worden, wäre das Geschrei jetzt auch groß gewesen, weil irgendjemand Zugriff auf eure Postfächer hatte.
Insofern schwierig natürlich komisch und so und aber ich glaube dass gerade im,
In der IT des Deutschen Bundestages dann so Datenschutz auch äh groß geschrieben wird und da hättet,
Hätten die, äh wenn ich das da, wenn ich das zumindest in Unternehmen wäre es so gewesen, dass.
Der Mitarbeiter, ja, in dem Fall der äh der oder die Abgeordnete, den Forensika.
Oder sein Arbeitgeber oder was von dem Briefgeheimnis hätte befreien müssen, um den Zugang zu diesen E-Mails,
zu ermöglichen. Insofern glaube ich, dass es datenschutzrechtlich nicht möglich gewesen wäre, diese E-Mail einfach zu entfernen.
Ähm aber wie gesagt, ich hoffe, dass wenigstens dieser Link jetzt äh.
Gesperrt ist und was natürlich eigentlich nochmal ganz interessant wäre, wer jetzt zu schauen, wie diese E-Mail abgesendet wurde, ne? Ähm aber ja, mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit
wird auch da die Spur ins Nichts führen oder wenn sie es nicht getan hätte dann wäre das jetzt auch im Rahmen dieser Berichterstattung die Ergebnisse wahrscheinlich mitgeteilt worden.
Und ganz kurz noch, dass es äh da sieht, ist nach einem interessanten Sieg aus das Gerichtsverfahren von Nick Maril gegen das FBI
Nick Mary hatte vor elf Jahren einen National Security Letter bekommen und hat sich ein
Über ein Jahrzehnt dauernd den Rechtsstreit jetzt dahin gegeben der hat einen kleinen Internet Provider gehabt und in diese National Security Letters sind ja diese Briefe, denen gesagt wird, gib uns,
Folgende alle Daten und sprich mit niemandem darüber, auch nicht mit deinem Anwalt, du hast keine Möglichkeit, dich äh rechtlich hier gegen zur Wehr zu setzen
Sondern du musst einfach Folge leisten mit unserem äh Verlangen hier. Und da hat sich eben äh Nicklas Maril damals gegen,
versucht zu wehren und jetzt irgendwie über eine Dekade an Rechtsstreit hinter sich. Da gibt es jetzt gerade ein Urteil, wo,
äh er gewonnen hat, wo gesagt wird, er darf diesen.
Den Inhalt dieses National Security Letters veröffentlichen,
und ihm wurde quasi Unrecht getan damit, dass er äh dass er, wie er da eingeschränkt wurde,
Aber ähm das FBI hat oder die Regierung, US-Regierung hat noch neunzig Tage ähm,
Widerspruchsrecht. Deswegen bleibt der Gag-Order, obwohl er nicht rechts nach nach Rechtsprechung dieses nach und nach, nach dem Urteil dieses Gerichtes nicht rechts.
Konform ist, bleibt er trotzdem noch neunzig Tage äh in Kraft,
weil das FBI sich ja gegen diese Klage äh nochmal äh erpielen kann, also die die UR die US-Regierung quasi nochmal ähm wie wie nennt man das,
Berufung einlegen kann.
Genau, dagegen klagen kann.
Ja, der Artikel, den wir hier verlinken, äh erwähnt auch noch, dass die IFF der Meinung ist, dass so ungefähr dreihunderttausend solcher äh Briefe verschickt worden sind seit zweitausendeins. Das ist eine Schätzung. Schon eine ganze Menge, dreihunderttausend.
Für vierzig Jahre.
Ja, das und das ist nicht nur die IFF, das äh Justizministerium hat schon zweitausendacht
geschlossen, dass das FBI diese äh Macht äh in vielen Fällen ausgenutzt hat, also
zu Unrecht eingesetzt hat, Informationen,
über eine große Anzahl von US-Bürgern gesammelt hat und damit ihre Rechte nach dem ersten verletzt hat,
Und keinerlei.
Ja und keinerlei,
Paper angelegt hat. Das heißt, es gibt noch nicht mal irgendeine Dokumentation davon, bis dann irgendwann zweitausendsechs ein paar äh ähm,
in den äh regulatorischen Rahmenbedingungen dieser International Security Letters eingeführt wurden. Aber äh viele Jahre lang,
hat das FBI diese Macht, also missbraucht und tut es sicherlich auch heute noch.
Gut, das bringt uns äh zu den Terminen.
Ja und wir fangen an, wie vorhin schon eingangs erwähnt, mit der Veranstaltung Jugendhakt in diesem Fall allerdings die Variante, die noch in Berlin stattfinden wird und zwar das vom,
sechzehnten bis achtzehnten Oktober und äh wer Lust hat, da noch sich anzumelden, hat vielleicht noch die Gelegenheit dazu.
In Dresden finden vom vierundzwanzigsten bis zum fünfundzwanzigsten Oktober die Datenspuren in den technischen Sammlungen.
Und ein weiterer Termin und zwar der selbe Termin in Berlin wiederum ist der Refugee Hackeshorn. Hier gibt's die äh Möglichkeit für Flüchtlinge an einem Heckesorn teilzunehmen.
Das Ganze geht schon am Freitag los mit einem Anforderungsworkshop.
Und an den beiden darauffolgenden Tagen, dem vierundzwanzigsten und fünfundzwanzigsten sollen die Ideen vom Anforderungsworkshop,
umgesetzt werden, also Apps für Flüchtlinge, Mitarbeiterinnen von Flüchtlingsorganisationen,
Grasfood zu Organisationen, aber auch Behörden, alles, was man tun kann, um unsere neuen Mitbürgern Hilfe zu leisten.
Was ist in München los?
In München findet vom neunten bis zehnten Oktober der Zündfunk Netzkongress im Münchner Volkstheater statt.
Bist du auch dabei?
Und ich bin dabei äh und das ist vielleicht der einzige nicht ganz relevante, netzpolitische Teil der sechste auf Podcaster Workshop findet in Berlin statt, dreizehnter bis fünfzehnter November,
Diese Anmeldungen, wie alle anderen Infoseiten. Toll, verlinkt in unseren Shownotes.
So, Linus, jetzt war's das aber auch.
War aber noch mal Tim.
Ja, total, wir sind raus äh. Ähm.
Wir sind, glaube ich, ein bisschen nervös, weil wir uns jetzt hier wieder so äh ohne so so ungeschminkt gegenübersitzen und äh ne, kein, kein Internet, was uns hindert.
Wir sind einfach scheiße vorbereitet. Das ist alles. Aber passt schon. Äh wir müssen jetzt feiern gehen, die Nuss,
feiern jetzt mal. So, ihr könnt auch feiern. Gab ja wieder viele tolle Nachrichten, die man feiern kann.
Ja, hey, ist doch super, hä?
Ah, ihr wisst ja, ne, das Lachen darf uns nicht vergehen. Insofern ähm oder irgendjemand zu danken? Ja, zwei Leuten habe ich zu danken. Hm, nur zwei. Ja. Hm.
Ja, zwei Leuten habe ich zu danken. Ja, danke und danke, weil beide sind mir leider unbekannt.
Ja, die äh habe ich auch schon mal getroffen, glaube ich.
Meldet euch doch gerne mal.
Genau und alle, äh die auch sonst äh uns hier immer wieder unterstützen,
und äh auch nur weiter erzählen, was wir hier machen und äh anderen Leuten empfehlen, neues Buch Netzpolitik zu hören. Auch dafür äh bedanken wir uns. Und zwar mit einer neuen Sendung in der nächsten Woche. Bis bald, tschüss.
Ciao ciao.